[Music]
when I think about taking a train I get
this warm fuzzy nostalgic feeling sort
of like of course the reality of train
travel in America is less than magical
it's just huge parts of this country
where it's just a hassle to get you know
anywhere by train and the trains barely
run you build the only for the most part
the only passenger trains are you or
Amtrak that's the case it's been poor
you know almost 50 years now even along
the busy Northeast Corridor stretching
from Washington DC to Boston less than
10% of trips each year are taken by
train so it might be surprising to learn
that this guy a billionaire investor who
co-owns the Milwaukee Bucks basketball
franchise is super optimistic about the
future of trains in America it has a
plan to bring them back
I think people lack imagination a little
bit sometimes of what actually could
happen and once they can experience it I
think it'll be a question of you know
why is it not every place else
[Music]
so how did trains get such a bad rap in
America
here's a little background just over a
hundred years ago train travel was
really the only option for long distance
trips but as two major technological
innovations came online
you know passenger rails competiveness
dropped significantly one of those of
course is the car and then to combine
those vehicles with a massive amount of
highway construction the other major
technological innovation of course was
the airplane both of those you know were
heavily subsidized by the federal
government and you know as a result the
number of riders on passenger trains you
know started to plummet and so the
railroad companies they were losing all
sorts of money on their passenger lines
so they wanted to you know dump them so
they basically convinced the federal
government in 1971 to create the Amtrak
and basically take over any city
passenger rail in the busy Northeast
Corridor Amtrak actually runs a fairly
popular reliable service but in most of
the rest of the country where Amtrak
doesn't even own its own tracks frequent
delays are the norm and ticket sales are
dismal but of course it doesn't have to
be this way in much of europe and asia
taking an intercity train is as natural
as it is for americans to hop into their
own cars
there's a dramatic and large-scale
public investment in rail News Asia
Western Central Europe that's just not
an investment we've made here in the US
so we just have significantly less
service on offer but in some ways you
could see that as a glass-half-full and
there's a tremendous amount of
opportunity there the question is you
how can we build more of it how can we
afford that service and where's that
service going to work fast
[Music]
bright-line announcing it's just a few
weeks away from service in Miami Jade
and they started testing the tracks
today here in Miami a city founded by
Gilded Age railroad magnate Henry
Flagler a new grand rail experiment is
taking place the first brand-new
privately owned intercity passenger rail
service in America in nearly a century
it's the brainchild of this guy Wes
Whedon's head of private equity firm
fortress Investment Group how do you
help convince a culture that isn't
really interested in train as
transportation to become interested in
trains as transportation get him to try
it once
not only is at the time the efficiency
of it it's a very very pleasurable
experience it's a proven commodity
around the world it's only the United
States in the industrialized world it
doesn't have it I think that's gonna
change soon
Wes his project called bright line
started operating in 2018 running modern
siemens built passenger trains between
Miami Fort Lauderdale in West Palm Beach
it speeds it up to around 70 miles per
hour running on existing freight track
owned by the Florida East Coast railroad
by 2022 the route will be extended up to
Orlando on newly built tracks that will
allow the trains to cruise at up to 125
miles per hour the entire 250 mile route
will take around three hours falling
into an important passenger rail sweet
spot it's too short to fly but too long
to drive
you know if it's too short then rail
service doesn't really make much sense
people are gonna take their color and
then you're talking a thousand miles
Aviation is always gonna be competitive
but furred that kind of 2 to 500 mile
range rail service really offers
potentially the best alternative these
paired quarters they're too far to drive
to short to fly there's about a dozen
significant ones so Atlanta to Charlotte
Dallas to Houston Las Vegas to Los
Angeles which is our next project and I
think that it's quite possible you'll
see trains in all those places over the
next and I actually grew up in South
Florida not far from where bright lines
were out passes today my parents like
many other transplants escaped cold
crowded New York for the tropical
laid-back charm of South Florida and
like most of the u.s. Florida has a
firmly entrenched car culture but in
recent decades
Florida's population has surged as
retiring baby boomers have been lured in
by the state's lack of income and estate
taxes traffic especially on the i-95
chord has become a nightmare at all
hours have you done the drive from West
Palm to Miami before I have what's that
like that's better
you're stuck in at least two for the
hour
Florida drivers are talented there's a
witness they make New York drivers look
like they just got out of driving school
a lot of them are New Yorkers who just
made the way down Jenner brought the
guide school it's not hard to see how a
train would be an improvement over all
of that but logic aside there's still
the strong cultural bias against trains
that bad reputation so bright-line
sweetens the deal and for about eighteen
to forty dollars each way you get to
ride on a bright clean
brand-spankin'-new train with some
luxury flavored amenities and finally
there's the biggest luxury of all
reducing your carbon footprint we think
will take four million cars off the road
here you know millions of metric tons of
co2 this system will run on biodiesel
obviously it's not fossil free but
you're concentrating people into
transportation which is a lot more
efficient than individual car for all
these potential upsides Breitling has
already faced some serious challenges
one is a bizarrely high level of
fatalities caused by collisions a bright
line train comes to a smashing stop
hitting a car on the tracks officials
say that this person who was in this
vehicle is okay
these accidents are pretty clearly not
the railways fall it's more like risky
Floridian drivers are used to ignoring
crossing warnings to get past
slow-moving freight trains to their
credit bright line has undertaken some
measures to reduce these accidents such
as improving signage at crossings and
using drones to monitor potential
collisions the real hurdle though is the
business itself the total bill for
bright lines completed Orlando to Miami
route is expected to come in at around
four billion dollars funded mostly by
what are called private activity bonds a
form of tax-exempt bonds sold to private
investors eventually the bonds will need
to be repaid so far ridership has been
climbing last July they welcomed their 1
million thry Durr but on a Tuesday
afternoon while this is what our train
looked like
I walk by dogs every morning and every
time that goes by I kind of look
to help increase ridership they've
partnered with everyone from local
museums to ride-sharing services to the
Miami Heat
and more recently they announced a brand
new partnership with this guy which will
result in bright line being renamed
Virgin Trains USA sometime in 2020 but
bright line isn't just betting on
ridership what train service does always
really well it's not just making money
on a service it's that knowing the land
around train stations is incredibly
valuable and bright lines parent company
effectively owns land in particular
around the station in Central Miami you
know we've built about a million and a
half square feet of real estate I mean
this is a part of Miami that you would
know well was not really a vibrant
economic zone it now is really the hub
of economic you know development here in
downtown Miami any transportation plays
a huge role not so we think that the
real estate part of it is a big
component and actually linking those two
things together economically creates a
lot of the foundation for either project
bright lines Florida route isn't the
only recent development for passenger
rail in the u.s. the company's next
project is a high-speed electric train
stretching from Las Vegas to just
outside LA a route millions of tourists
drive every year other high-speed rail
projects have been proposed in places
like Texas and the Pacific Northwest
though these proposals are far behind
bright lights operational service
[Music]
meanwhile Amtrak isn't taking all of
this private competition line down a
couple of years ago it brought on
Richard Anderson a CEO who previously
revived Delta Airlines from bankruptcy
we really need reposition Amtrak as a
modern mode of transportation similar to
what we see in Europe and what we see in
Japan he's been cutting costs in an
effort to free up capital for
much-needed infrastructure improvements
and revamps trains like these
state-of-the-art high-speed cars that
are coming in 2021 to the business
traveler focused Accela line while
Amtrak still needs subsidies to get by
it's financially healthier than ever and
in 2019 it set a new record for
ridership serving nearly a million more
passengers than the year prior
ultimately the future of American
passenger rail whether public or private
will depend on one really big question
will Americans want to actually ride
trains or do we prefer to think of them
as nostalgia inducing relics of the past
rail has always made sense but it you
know it seems like it's never made more
sense than in 2020 we need more of it
you know there's the climate issue the
less people drive the less people fly
you know the better it is for the
environment countries that invest in
infrastructure are the ones that do the
best do the best economically do the
best for the people to create the best
quality of life we used to be the leader
of infrastructure in the world and I
think frankly we're not the leader
anymore
and that's something that should change
[Music]
you